welcome to episode 41 of the mckayla
peterson podcast
if you enjoyed these episodes please
remember to rate and subscribe
do not rate them if you do not like them
in this episode i spoke with yun mi park
if you haven't heard of her she has an
incredible story of escaping north korea
and then being sold into slavery in
china and eventually ending up in the
states
her whole story is available in a book
called in order to live
i listened to it on audible and cried a
lot
after listening to her story it really
makes me
wonder kind of i guess how people
can complain about animal rights or
climate and
why they're not focusing on things like
entire nations being
sold into slavery or forced into slavery
more like
but i suppose that's because it's easier
to complain about
people eating meat and driving cars than
it is to figure out how to make a
country stop enslaving their population
this was a very intense episode she's an
intense human
i'd like to take a second to mention
ground news a sponsor of the show and a
canadian company that i really support
not that i do ads for companies that i
don't support
but they have a cool platform they
they're a comparison news
platform so instead of trying to find an
unbiased news platform which is
very difficult although i still
recommend doing that
they'll compare how sources from across
the political spectrum are covering
a story so you can easily see how
outlets are manipulating a story to fit
an underlying narrative if they are
which they often are especially this
year
they'll show an article and it'll say 55
left 27
center 18 right something like that they
have an app called ground news
which i recommend checking out so ground
news is an apolitical news app
interested in giving you the full story
regardless of your political ideology
you can download their free app and
browser extension you can click
on the link in the description below or
go to ground.news
i use it to judge what i'm reading i'd
also like to thank
murtycreative.co for continuing to
support me
i got a leather journal for andre for
christmas
he's outside so i have to be quiet but
he doesn't listen or watch these so
no worries on him finding out i'm gonna
get one with my logo on the front
they're an american company that makes
handmade leather goods that really last
i've had my journal for about two years
you can get whatever you buy folio
binder cup holder journal
engraved for free if you enter the code
mp
they also have a podcast available on
youtube at mertycreative.co
where they talk about how to start a
small business and troubles that come
along with it
i really recommend journaling to people
handwritten journaling
specifically to get your anxieties and
worries out without looking at a screen
it's a nice thing to do for five or ten
minutes at night or in the morning
check out murtycreative.co and use
codemp
for engravings on leather goods i hope
you enjoyed this episode
i need to do some more about china i
think because i really don't know a lot
about what's going on over there but it
doesn't sound good
i'd also like to wish everybody a merry
christmas soon
[Music]
welcome to my podcast thank you so much
for having me it's our real honor
you have an absolutely incredible story
um i'm not completely done your book
because i reached well we connected so
quickly and then i wanted to have you on
the podcast right away
so i haven't had a chance to get all the
way through it but i've definitely got
through most of it and i've cried a lot
um so can we start
off would you give a bit of an
introduction about who you are
and what it is that you do yeah so i
was born in north korea in the 1993
and i escaped in 2007
then i came to america around five years
ago
and now i work as a human rights
activist
okay so that's that's a lot
let's start with uh how did you manage
to
get out so it was 2007
and i was 13 years old and
in north korea the main thing that kills
is a starvation it's like a man-made
famine like if you read the hunger games
in the book
there's a captor and there's different
13 districts
and the cat are on purposely keeping
other people
hungry so imagine like if the population
were fed
they are going to start thinking about
like the meaning of life
but when we are all hungry or all we can
think of a survivor every second
we don't have time to think about
freedom or whatever it is
so i think eventually just hunger drove
us to escape to china
and i crossed the frozen river to china
in march of 2007
so so living in north korea um
was there a difference between what you
experienced from the 90s to 2007 and
what your parents experienced when they
were growing up
yeah there was a huge difference like uh
when i was born in 1993 the end of it
that's like right after the soviet union
collapsed
so they were stopped aiding north korea
and north korea is like central governed
the economy
people cannot trade they cannot start
business
everything has to be provided by the
regime the government the socialist
system
so therefore my parents when they were
born in the 60s and 70s
when they were going to school they were
still like relatively
you know well off that even south
koreans
first say because they were getting a
lot of help from china and
soviet union and other countries but
however like
by the time in the 90s when when i was
born soviet union stopped helping north
korean regime
and of course they went out all the
money resources everything
then the weir this like the hair began
in north korea
so when i was born i even never
experienced any public distribution
even though like a social system that is
like a main thing should keep us alive
but
they wouldn't just give us anything and
therefore
around from 1990 1995
to 1998 during that three years
more than three million people north
korea died from starvation
it was like the one of the worst famines
in 21st
history so there's a little bit more
information now but it's hard to get
information about what actually goes on
in there
and you come across the occasional
person that goes oh it's you know it's
not as bad as people are saying
um so what
let's start with a topic like internet
do people have access to internet
no we don't even know the word of
internet
there is no so in north korea like there
are a lot of words that we don't have
like the words love romantic love
doesn't exist
and like if you read 1984 by georgia
ware
it talks about the newspeak the northern
regime
made this like new almost language for
the people
so there's no word for friend for
instance you and i can never be friends
we only can allow to call each other
comrades
wow yeah the words like friend doesn't
exist the word
like of course internet no way human
rights
like i when i was like in south korea to
escape
when i heard the word animals rights i
was
so shocked because in north korea people
don't even know
they have rights as a human beings and
the rest of the world
like know about like animals rights like
that's why north korea is a completely
different universe
yeah yeah okay okay so internet what
about electricity
we do have electricity very very
occasionally like few times a year
and even though like when you get this
like little bit of electricity
we can it's not like comes like 20 20
volt or like 110 volt
very low so people have to have a
transformer to
make the electricity look like visible
so most of people do not like
rely on their electricity or like
central healing anything they are like
lifestyles very medieval you know we
like we find the core
rules like anything we could to burn and
cook things
okay um for you hear about how people
react to the regime um are there people
there
who are actual supporters who have been
i guess you would say brainwashed
into thinking that people running the
country
are gods is is any of that true
yeah it's a religion like in north korea
we don't even know that we are asians
they say we are like kimura some race
and the northern calendar doesn't begin
when the jesus christ was born
it begins when the first king was born
in 1912
april 15th and north korea even has a
different time zone than south korea
so it's completely different planet you
can imagine they had definitely common
sense
so even after my escape from north korea
to china
i would still like believe that kim's
could read my thoughts
so what the nursing regime did that they
copied the bible
saying that you know jesus died by his
spirit with us forever
right and like that like kids of course
die
physically but their spirit leaves us
forever they don't know
what we think how many like you know
hair we have you know on our head
it's a completely religion and when they
indoctrinate us with that religion
and also if they don't have internet
they'll
only have one child on tv they have only
one newspaper
then like people do not get any out of
the information then that that's like
what we think is the word is
that's that's so hard to imagine
for like it's so hard to imagine it
sounds like a
horrifying tv show it's like uh living
in there feels like you know living in a
treatment the entire thing is set
everybody's lying there's no public
survey ever
i never even heard the word like public
survey because nobody cares what we
think
our opinion doesn't matter like in north
korea we are not even allowed to call
ourselves
i like even though i said i like this
pen i said we say love this paint
we love red color so the same in the
word i
is like something so like not like
appropriate in that society
individualism is the worst thing you can
do in north korea
what what happens if somebody starts to
criticize the
via the regime well they are gonna be
executed but not only themselves the
three generations of their family
cannot be sent to prison camp and be
punished sometimes up to eight
generations
so like uh people yeah so we don't even
know what that means
but like i don't know how that's
possible that what they do is that
like they find someone in that family
three generations and then their cousins
marry somebody then they are like inlaws
of the in-laws in-laws
so a lot of times when this persecution
happens they don't even know that
they were related to that person so do
you do you remember that the kim jong-un
killed his uncle i don't know very much
about any of this to be honest
yeah so like when kim jong-un the latest
kim came to power he like
executed his uncle and then because of
that one guy more than 30
000 people died or sent to prison camp
one person like this is called guilty by
association
so if somebody in your family or like
your
in-laws come in a certain crime you all
get punished together
that's why revolution is impossible
okay i had some i asked my instagram if
they had questions about
your story and a ton of people did and
one of the questions that i thought
was actually somewhat silly um was
why don't people revolt yeah and that
would be the answer because you'll die
yeah but the main reason before that was
that most of people do not know they are
slaves
they do not know they live under the
dictatorship
so when you don't know you're a slave
how do you fight to be free
so how did yeah yeah how did your family
know to escape to china or know that
there was something different out there
we didn't know we were lucky enoughly to
live on the border town of north korea
and if you look at the like satellite
photos of north korea and nights
it is literally the darkest place on
earth right now
so at night i was able to see
electricity coming from china
and i thought like at 13
maybe if i go where the lights were i
might find
something to eat
it wasn't like we knew the world was bad
i didn't even know like
never seen the matter of the world i
didn't even know what africa was what
canada
was obviously like only thing i learned
were like
americans about they called like
american masters
japanese in paris south korea china
maybe russia
that's all about it the word so i had no
clue what was it like just
crossing the river i thought maybe they
might some have food for me
jesus so how how did you
manage to get through what
you've gone through and stay sane
like how have you managed because that's
odd that's
more trauma than most people will be
able to imagine just even just having
that
switch and trying to understand where
you came from so how have you managed
that
well i mean i wouldn't like say like
every day i'm like happy over joy but
you're jumping and down but i do have
difficult days
but it's like when you go something like
that you know that
this is a bubble that where i am the
fact that you even know the word
trauma that is like privilege like in
north korea nobody talks about trauma
nobody talks about like
what you went through as a heart because
your life right now is current hair
so i think that keeping that perspective
is really helped me going online like
you know like i went through all the
hair
to survive and now i'm gonna be bitter
about it about what i went through like
what is the point of doing any of that
to survive
so i think the perspective really helped
me
okay well that's a good point you
managed to make it out then
try not to be stuck there how did how
did you
manage to catch up in everything you
hadn't learned
and how long did that take you i'm still
taking me
right now but i think the books
i think the one hardest thing that when
i arrived in south korea
so like i went through china and then at
13 i was stored to
human traffickers and i became a sexual
slave in china
and my mom was started for 65 dollars
and i was for like 200
over 20 dollars in this 21st century
like this labor is happening right now
like at this very point we are talking
so two years of being in china as a
slave we
walked across the gobi desert to
mongolia from china
in mongolia that's when we became free
we went to south korea
so arriving in south korea after seeing
all of that horror that humans can
afflict on another
it was very hard to trust again you know
it was uh
that was like the toughest thing i ever
done like how do i trust ever again and
books like why i was reading you know
george orwell's books like animal farm
in 1984 brave new word and later of
course dr jordan peterson's book
it just the books really gave me the
meaning and
direction and made me understand the
word and what i went through
so what are your plans for the future
like what are you trying to do with what
you went through
i'm trying to free my people
there are still 25 north koreans are
living in the dark and
dark i mean darkness and entire
countries like her making them the
concentration camp
but like north korean entire border is
shared with
land mines and electrified wire fences
the entire country is a prison so
how can we as a humanity say you know we
go to the mars we go to the moon and we
are keep moving forward as a
civilization but we
left 25 minutes behind in that
prison camp on the kim jong-un so
it's my that's the meaning that i find
where i want to free my people
because i saw what was happening there
do you have suggestions for what to do
because
that like that is a that's a huge
problem and i know places like america
get a lot of criticism for going into
other countries and saying
hey you should be more like us yeah
so what can so two questions what
is this something government should be
actively
fighting and involved in would that end
uh it
it would that result in more deaths over
there
so that's part one of the question
so whatever happens things cannot be
worse than what it is now
like it's impossible like i was doing
this
surgery at 13 in north korea i had this
stomach and they took me to hospital and
they cut me off my belly they don't have
of course
x-rays and without any anesthesia
and then they the nurses use one meter
to inject on everybody
and literally there were piles of human
bodies dead outside in from the hospital
and
that's eating human eyes first and
children change those rats
because they're hungry that is north
korea so no way
no nobody on earth things can get worse
than what it is right now
i think what the world should do is now
really
the kingdom can never exist by himself
it is enabled by ccp in china the
communist party
in china they've been funding this
dictatorship
they've been sponsoring it for the last
75 years
why because uh china doesn't want
north korea to be falling into democracy
like south korea
is and north korea is their buffer zone
from the democracy this movement coming
from
south korea and japan and america and
the u.s army base in south korea said
so china really needs north korea to
defend their border
so they don't that get the influence
from other countries of this freedom and
democracy
yeah okay that makes sense so yes is
your answer this should be stopped
by everyone as soon as possible uh
yeah what what can the average person do
i think that is the one thing the
raising awareness
that what is actually going on and the
we constantly talking about slavery
happened like hundreds of years ago
but it's still happening right now like
there are 300 000 north korean defectors
like myself
right now in china are slaves
and they are priced right now like if
you go chinese gold like baidu
you can buy a girl for 70 750 dollars
you can sleep with them for three
dollars five dollars you just rate them
and these things are like right not up
in chinese websites like online
platforms so people really need to talk
about
what is happening right now in our world
not only something happened in the past
and they also can get involved with you
know nonprofits
and there are a lot of like on my
youtube channel i talk about the
nonprofits that i support they can go
get involved with ngos
and be the spokesperson to just even
educate themselves firsthand that would
be enough
because most people don't even know that
mainstream media
hasn't been covered in north korean
issues because it involves china
and that hollywood of course do not want
to make any movies that upset china
so even though the movie is made for
north korea
they all drop the adventure because they
don't want to like release it to upset
[ __ ] wow
okay this is a lot what do you think is
going on there now
with the kim jong-un heart attack and
his sister
like do you know what's happening with
that at all yeah so
kim jong is pretty much alive he's not
the healthiest man
but he's very capable of making all the
decisions
and he has a very strong power
he he got the older power that he can
get
then now people being sent to a lot of
um
this camps detention camps too if you
get covered in north korea
you get sent to detention camp and they
don't feed you or they don't give you
medicine so if their
family members cannot afford to give
them food they have to die in the
descent big
detention camp right now like the double
hdl says the 6 000 people show those
symptoms
only in capture so for like 32 000
people in pyongyang
and we don't even know what the rest of
the country is like
so the countries are completely messed
with the covet and the by the regime
keep saying there's zero cases and
refused to help people do you think the
reason this information is
isn't more spread around let's say north
america
um is because of the ties with china
that has been my i've been working as a
activist for the last
five six years and you know they
were willing to help me on if as long as
i like criticized trump
new york times loves me of course for
that but then as long as i talk about
the
horrors that we expect in china and how
chinese regime
is the main problem of nursing problem
of course they don't talk about it they
will cut it out
so it's been so hard to raise awareness
about this because
kim jong-un is not the only responsible
person for this chinese regime actually
is like main responsible
that we need to call them accountable
for that
i did not know that exactly yeah
jesus okay um
why do people i know you get criticism
online and you have people that tell you
that you're lying about your story
so who are those people and why is that
happening
so i'm very hated by marxist maui
slandinist
socialist communists right because north
korea is the last country
in this earth right now horses
ideological to socialism
they themselves describe themselves as a
socialist paradise
north korea's name is not nurses dpik
democratic people's
republic of korea as democratic you know
so it's socially they
they vote they people vote but they got
only one guy to
vote for like north korea holds
elections every five years
is not a dictatorship technically
because they have elections
but when you go vote there's only one
person you should vote why even bother
because of socialism it's a socialist
paradise like that states say why they
have to
say i'm elected by the people so
therefore like this is the last country
holds his ideology and
what happens is that the people
anti-america anti-freedom capitalism
hates like america and they know that
norway's enemy of them
so they hate me for me supporting free
market
capitalism democracy free speech and
also people
like like i also made mistakes sometimes
like when i was
giving speeches i taught myself english
when i was like 21
and i did not know the difference
between here and mountain
so technically they say it's supposed to
be here i i climbed it three years but i
thought it was mountain how the
heck i know though what are to do do you
differentiate it
and when i was translating words to like
korean words to
english words it was grass but turns out
what i ate was plants
so there were like few things that i
made a mistake like oh so that's what
they go
after as if they know more than one
language yeah
right so like i said why why are you
saying grass is a plant
so you're lying so you climb like i saw
the google earth and it's supposed to be
here it's not a mountain but like i was
13 years old
i had no google earth how do i know it
was like so
that is like what their problem is but
the mainly is like
also i'm on the target list of kim
jong-un i mean he of course
tried because i spoke about my
regeneration
my family i left behind in north korea
or been persecuted
they have denounced me and they've been
executed or sent to prison camp
i have no clue so you know north korea
has a lot of hackers and the
these armies of hackers to try to
character assassinate people
who i mean who like criticize the regime
so a lot of people do not like me are
you concerned about your safety
oh yeah i mean i get informed about
intelligence all the time like oh my god
you're a threat like
and you scare me a lot like you know the
intelligence calls you and say like stop
it
intelligence from where south korea
because i used to live in south korea
yeah so well i mean that was scary
you know but yeah but the thing is you
know i could have been dead
so many times and almost like this is
like a second life that was given to me
and
i'm not going to live in fear again you
know i was the first thing my mom told
me when i was child when i was born in
north korea that
don't even whisper because the birds and
mice could hear me
i was so afraid even to think and now i
mean that is not why i risked my life
and going through all of this
to be free so if i get killed like you
know kim jong kid
is a hot brother in malaysia a few years
ago so if
he wants to kill me nothing gonna stop
it no
i'm like against the most brutal
dictator in the world it's not up to me
to live or not
so you know i just do my best to speak
my truth
until whenever that is gonna be what's
your opinion on
the north american view of what
suffering is
like say millennials or or gen z
and their complaints about life nowadays
it's going to be annoying
where i i know like i went to columbia
university in new york
okay and oh my gosh
that was uh that really made me scared
you know like by the time when i was
born in north korea
i didn't even know what alternative life
was possible
like my grandma knew like she was living
under the like japanese colonialism
but because that generation kept it
silent by the time when i was around
north korea
i didn't even know what love was i
didn't even know what
liberty was so
that is very scary right now like we are
keep eliminating things that we cannot
talk about
we cannot discuss and if we all stay
silent
out of fear like who the heck is gonna
be when
when it comes to our grandchildren they
are never even gonna know the word like
now existed
yeah you get a lot of people um right
now
especially with the political
correctness thing that's going on in
north america you have a lot of people
say oh i'm
scared and that's why i don't say
anything yeah but that sounds like less
of a good excuse if you
escape from north korea yeah i mean
that's but the thing is like
it is i mean people i mean this is how
the authoritarian regime starts like
how the government speak becomes like
this and
try to silence anybody else who
disagrees right like in
in capitalism you can be socialists you
can be communists we can coexist
with them like it's wonderful i mean
whoever had things so-called socialism
is great communism
i'm fine with that i don't like i can
think that clapton isn't great
but if you are capitalist in socialism
you're gonna be executed
but that is the difference like if your
capitalists believe in free market in
north korea
you will be sent to prison camp and
executed three with three generations of
your family
but the beauty of america is that i can
co-exist to the aoc like i can
be friends with the people who worship
socialism
i'm like i'm fine with it but like the
point is when like they cannot
they they want me to accept their faith
as something
god-given face you know so i cannot
think differently
and i think that's what's happening in
america and
it's been really scary like this year
i've been
i've been really like i used to think oh
america is great like their freedom is
never gonna like
go away but i see like how freedom is in
fragile
and it's just one dimensional way we can
just lose it
yeah yeah this year has been scary
seeing how quickly things can
deteriorate even with the
protesting and i mean that's part of
what happens when you're supposed
to lock down people and make them stay
inside right then
they're they're not going to be too
happy you know i mean like right like
people say like
how how ridiculous the governments tell
you what kind of haircut to have in
north korea right that's like the west
made fun of north koreans in the past
like north koreans have to have certain
haircuts
like look like kim jong-un you know they
made that like certain haircut available
for the people
you can of course like your haircut
you're going to go to prison right now
you know
if you look like that so like they make
you
like they send you prison for wearing
jeans and people like that's so
ridiculous now we're in the country
where you get
fined if you put don't put that on like
mask on in certain states
and they tell you how many people can
sit in your dinner table for like
thanksgiving
like this is like this is really exactly
what happened in north korea the regime
told us
when we can go out what we wear what we
sing what we listen to what we watch
and people get even executed in order to
watch a wrong movie
and like it just begins like this how do
you
that's that's horrifying that's um how
do you
i've heard a lot about smuggling um for
people trying to get things into north
korea
um is that when you were there i suppose
was
was that common or like did people talk
about it
or is it a certain group of people that
are able to
get things into that country and try and
get them out
how does that work yeah so like
if because north korea and socialism
trading is
technically illegal you cannot
governments need to like
make all the money make all the
resources and like distribute to people
equally
right so that you can not in order you
can own a car you can own a house
you cannot own anything there's no
private property
you cannot even like own a cow that's
the thing so
but the people like because the regime
stopped giving people food in 1990s then
what do we have to do we have to find a
way to survive and
like that's the natural thing people do
is a trading
that is how the trading begins like
that's the only way we can survive
and then some people in the border town
went to china and brought goods
and started this like smuggling business
it's not like everybody does it but it's
only like in the people
who live in the border towns who doesn't
like smuggling and
able to do some of that but now it's
completely shut down with the code with
everything
no no way anyone can do that right now
let's say there's no government that's
going to take this probable
problem on do you think north korea can
continue
going or because everyone like you said
is
starving is it going to is the problem
going to go away at some point
or do you think this could last for
quite a while
i if i didn't see how china chinese
communist party solidifies
their power with technology like
i wouldn't like now i say i don't know
because
look at china even though they're opened
up economically their political power is
stronger than ever before people like
have the social credit systems and they
cannot even take the bus
if they were not a good citizen in the
eyes of the communist party
and that's in china yes see i don't know
anything about this either
so face recognition cameras everywhere
you
they track your app while you write
everything's being censored if you said
something wrong
and was not a good citizen enough for
the communist party
you are not even allowed to buy a train
ticket to see your family
you lose your freedom of movement within
china even
not to imagine getting a transformation
yes so this is like happening in china
this
all ai the face recognition and all this
technology has been
going against for the individual liberty
and this is happening in north korea as
well kim jong has been buying all this
technology from china
swinging the town remember like in 1984
people see your camera and like they
know what you think
so people like like there's no way you
can escape that surveillance big brother
is watching
all the time and that is happening right
now on this earth
and that was when china mastered at it
and in north korea even in the poor
situation can't even afford electricity
they are buying these things from china
putting on the borders
putting on the town so they can see
who's out there who is not
who is the wrong person is in the in the
town because in north korea you
needed a permit to even go to a
different city you are not even able to
travel within
your own country so that's how they
restrict
control everybody and surveillance on
everyone
and like that's why like i mean
everybody everyone we thought like oh
freedom is not prepared we're gonna be
in this spot like no
like we gotta fight it that freedom is
not free like there's
a price for it to pay for so how come
this
i'm feeling uneducated during this
podcast but like how come
these issues with china aren't on the
front of newspapers
because i mean new york times cnn and
bbc
everybody needs their money from china
like do you know how china money gives
all the money to harvard yeah mit all
these ivy league schools
but they don't teach this stuff they're
not a lot they are taking
so much funding a lot of like ivy league
schools getting funding to do the
certain research and media companies i
was i mean hollywood
like look at disney this time they were
making some movie mulan
there are consensus and camps for the
muslims in xinjiang they sterilize women
they rape them like they go like a
falsely like
sterilized men and women so these
muslims cannot have more babies
and they their ends right there right
now this is like happening
and like this is like not the of course
main story on your times
we are not gonna know yeah it seems
slightly more important than covet
definitely it's definitely more
important than anything that
yeah it's like can you but imagine that
like if somebody told you last year that
someday government gonna have this much
power make you sure that you cover your
face every single time when you're
outside and you cannot travel you cannot
eat in
like would you have believed it yeah no
that's very true
if you just described what's going on
here now a year ago yeah
nobody there people would have said no
but that's the thing like
how people can make fun of north koreans
not revolting
this is how it all began yeah
there's nobody like going on the street
and fighting for our like rights right
now
right you're just all accepted because
the government says it
yeah although right now they're using
the excuse like i don't know what they
do you can tell me what they do in north
korea but here they're using the excuse
is keeping people safe
right the reason that we're doing all
these is so that there are fewer deaths
so how do they like what do they say i
mean in north korea it's straight up
will kill you right no it's all
manipulation they
say that our enemies like of course like
american bastards right they try to
attack us so it's like 1984 georgia
where these are enemies always trying to
attack us
and then our dear leader who's brave
enough to defend us and keep us safe
therefore we have to obey and then
eventually when we suffer on this life
when we die we are gonna all go to like
socialist paradise with him and have
forever eternal great life okay so it's
the same thing it's for your own safety
yeah it's a for your safety your chains
and children's future like
the regime is sacrificing so much for
you so i sincerely believed
when i was in north korea that the deal
leader was studying for me
i cried my heart broke because i thought
he was starving and suffering for other
people and i was like
so touched so grateful eternally
grateful for him
yeah i'm never gonna say i'm doing this
for my sake they're gonna always say
it's all free for your sex that's always
the manipulation comes
that's scary that makes that makes the
current situation here a little bit more
concerning
yeah okay well okay so say something
more positive then
well we'll get back into the negative
though um your experience
you've had so many like terrible
experiences um
and then you came to america so what was
that like
i came to america from south korea i was
writing a book
and that brought me to new york okay
okay so you lived how long were you in
south korea
i was in south korea five years so after
north korea i go to china
then mongolia then south korea then
america so i only came to america
like four or five years ago five years
ago and is that when you learned english
right before yeah i was watching
american show friends
and like lots of ted talks and npr that
helped me
you know practice my english and that's
how i came oh that's very impressive
i've been trying to vaguely trying to
learn russian through my husband and
it's not easy it's not easy yeah
so what was okay well then let's step
back a little bit you went from mongolia
to south korea
so what was that like it's tough it's
like
people think like freedom is easy it's
not it's very scary thing like
in north korea i never had to think
about my future
usually freedom is responsibility
and i think that's what people don't get
like freedom doesn't mean like all
exciting happy you have to be
responsible you have to work hard
you have to use all your mistakes and
suddenly i go to south korea they ask me
like
what's your favorite color i never had
to think about it in north korea my
favorite color was red
because it was a revolutionary color and
carbon told me so
and i started thinking for yourself
wasn't coming to me naturally at all
it was so hard in my brain like why do i
have to keep thinking what i like
what's my favorite even that was
challenging and then later figuring out
what i'm gonna do with my life was it
way more challenging than you know
figuring those things out so being in
south korea also very hard
there's so much discrimination against
north koreans
and then like you know i don't know like
south korea is obsessed with education
and i was like korean age like 17 years
old not that young
so i was still like doing addition and i
had never even seen the map of the world
don't even know the alphabet and have to
compete with these kids
who's been breed to like take a great
test and like study all their life
so it was like i was starting so late so
behind
i you know even in south korea i didn't
even have time to eat so i was like
going like into magnitude and going to
emergency room
that's how hard i try to catch up and
be responsible for my life how much
education had you got in north korea
before you
came out so where were you starting to
south korea
yeah so i didn't go to school when i was
like seven
or six like first i think totally i'll
take it like
one or you know two three semesters
so i learned how to write in korean in
north korea
and i did that i learned a basic like
math so when i was like when you go to
school like
seven eight right like those basic
things i learned
and then like after a few semester my
father was arrested
we were too poor to go to north korean
school even though it's technically free
education free health care
free of everything right the social is
paradise but
even though sadly free exchange is not
free so we couldn't afford
so i couldn't go to school when i was
like around eight
so you still have to pay to go to school
yeah tons of things you have to go give
to the school teachers everything it's
just unbelievable
and like what you learn in school is not
like even actually your education like
they teach you math
but the way how they teach you is like
there are four american masters
you killed two of them then how many
american basketball so that's real
yeah so like as like and then like when
they like
teach you some grammar like you said i
killed americans
i am killing americans i very kill
americans
that's like the grammar that's how they
teach you so every single thing they
teach you is true
tried to like brainwash you
and in a way maybe it was a good thing
that i didn't learn much of it
you know yeah i guess um and and do you
think people
like from an outsider outsider's
perspective if you hear something like
that like if you were
if you grew up somewhere free and you
were told to learn
grammar that way you would instantly
know that something was amiss
yeah but if you're if you grow up
in a place that isn't free do people
recognize that they're
being forced into this idea that let's
say americans are
evil or do they just because it starts
so young
yeah you start so young like how do you
like right now like can you
imagine life in the alien like planet
you can't you never seen one you never
heard about one
like you can't imagine it so you're only
gonna think the way that you think right
now
what you have seen in this country right
in this world like that like
as we cannot imagine life on mars north
korea can never imagine the
life outside of north korea yeah well
it's very difficult to change your
belief system
no matter what it is and i mean that's
part of the reason
i suppose people are having such trouble
in the states right now too is because
there's such a separation and
neither side wants to change or listen
yeah
um so i can understand that a bit um so
what's the last five years been like
since you got to new york
that has been crazy as you saw you know
i've been constantly attacked by these
maoist marxist leninist people
and constantly of course threatened by
the north korean regime they did
everything they were like do you
remember when this sony made the movie
called
interview the american there you have to
pull up the movie theaters and have them
all
i did not care about that yeah so the
north korea said if you show that movie
in america
i did hear about that is that that's why
they moved it right because they were
going to release it and then they didn't
release it for a little bit but they
were scared they were going to blow up
like
create another 1911 in american store so
they were all scared
imagine like right now like we are
actually
the north korean dictator can have that
much influence on our freedom here
when he's gonna stop his power is
growing and ever and we are getting
weakening in this country
people do not value freedom anymore they
don't care about freedom of speech
anymore
and the dictator's power is only gaining
more and more in china and north korea
so like that you know of course north
korea did everything they could to stop
my book get released with the penguin
random house
oh my gosh it was unbelievable
battle that we had to go through to get
that book released and
be okay afterwards and it was you know
this that's the thing in america like
people think oh you can say whatever you
want like no
you still have to fight the tyranny to
speak our minds and that's why
so precious to have freedom of speech
yeah well i'm good for penguin for
publishing the book yeah standing up for
i'm so
like grateful for them like they could
so easily like i want to put this off
it's so controversial so much attack so
unnecessary
why do we do this but they were standing
for their
integrity i think that's like really
hope
that people brave enough to take that
risk
[Music]
have you had any type of positive
experience since you've come to new york
is there anything you enjoy
well maybe not no i'm not at the moment
are you under lockdown right now
of course yeah yeah i think we're gonna
be under lockdown right away
again um so that's not as much fun but
like generally speaking how do you find
new york
i find people so wonderful in america i
mean this country's a beautiful country
right it's just
such a like whenever i put my foot on
this
sword i feel like he's like this is the
land of the free you know
despite all that divisiveness and the
media and like
those people in the establishment
whatever we say
i think people are still so wonderful
and what still shocks me is like how
people like
americans hug people and smile all the
time
you know like in north korea that's a
sign of weakness if you smile
because they're gonna get you they're
gonna attack you you have to be
so always tough and look for be paranoid
that helps you to be alive but in
america like people are so
whenever i take the photos they always
like put an effort to smile
and that's like that that's like even
surprising to me like
i remember first thing my father like
don't smile when you take a photo
because that's like the weakness and
here
people can just be like be loving be
compassionate be who they are
so yeah i love this country
and you're concerned about where it's
headed huh oh yeah
it's definitely i mean it's funny like i
went to dr peterson's speech in chicago
like three years ago or something oh
cool
and then back then i didn't get like
really resonated much
i was like oh i'm sure america is fine
but then i was
at columbia and then i was seeing it in
my eyes
and then i also started saying things
that wasn't politically correct
then what happens of course they come
get me as well even though i was
actually a slave
i shouldn't even laugh at that i know
like i i actually know what it feels
like to be a slave like it's not like i
read in the book
it's not something my ancestors went
through it like i lived through it
and this summer i was locked in like
middle of chicago
like downtown and the three black women
of course came and they punched me and
took my wallet it was a violent like
robbery
but it was like michigan avenue and and
then i was like
i wouldn't even call them like a dave i
was like can you wait i'm gonna call the
police so they can reserve this and then
they will start punching me
and the people on the street suddenly
yelling at me
because i was in a black and they were
saying like this
colored person doesn't make them fake
you're a racist
why are you doing this so they're
hurting me down so these girls can like
run away so i don't call the police on
them
so they don't get arrested and they they
i know like they stole my credit card
they they spent like thousand dollars
dollars of like in blooming there then
police got the footage and caught them
of course i'm not gonna prosecute them i
don't even have problems like
but the things that all they could see
at the moment was a color
like it was like what they were doing to
me or what we were doing just all the
pieces of black
and that's like that's why they're
supposed to be victims or something
and i'm not because i'm not a black the
people who are
after you like you know marxist leninist
are these mostly americans well
no they're coming all around the world
they are
a lot of them in south america there are
a lot of communist and socialists
in spain there are tons of people
brought there i mean
i'm not sure some people can't that but
definitely a lot from america
european countries even in asia too like
right now even south korea have this
crazy communist like uh
president who is like putting defectors
into prison
because they speak you know free they
practice the freedom of
speech right i think some kind of global
trend we are in all this developed
oyster countries
falling into this idea of diversity but
now diverse your thoughts about
diversity of what like
whatever it is they call it and they
have like zero tolerance for anyone who
can think different
and this is not just happening in
america it's happening in britain like
canada it's happening in south korea
like every where i see like it's
happening
and that's why i get attacked from like
globally
yeah okay that's fair uh you said you
went to colombia right
yeah so so what kind of degree did you
get from colombia
i was studying economics two years and
then i switched to political science and
human rights
okay and you know at human rights you
don't learn about holocaust obviously
you hold
you learn about the it's happening the
oppression that people are feeling right
now by
white like like straight oh man right
that's like
the human rights you learn it's not
about actually i mean like yeah it was
completely nonsense
the most useless degree i've ever got
and i'm just i'm glad i saw it the first
hand because otherwise i would think
why anyone in the same mind would do
that right
that's the thing like like i didn't get
it why would anyone in the same mind
do this to others and i saw in the first
hand that people can be this
irrational i think yeah it's a very
scary lesson to learn
yeah i mean that's the thing like the
people who put us in the
gas tankers were on other humans and
that's why i was so resonating to with
like 12 words for life this year again i
was
reliving it after seeing new things and
like just new perspective we think it's
like
that's like we you know i have seen the
worst in humanity and i have seen the
best like in the humanity
like trusting men ever again was the
hardest thing like
the first man i was saying was raping my
mom and then me
and constantly being raped by men and
how do i know they're good
yeah well okay so let's talk about that
for a second how on earth did you get
through that because
i mean there are a lot of people in
north america who have
some and like i'm gonna put it up some
shitty mildly shitty experience whereas
like
they both got too drunk and the guy was
a dick
but it wasn't enough to leave you
traumatized for the rest of your life it
was just a shitty experience and they
end up traumatized for the rest of their
lives so
how how do you manage to get go through
something involving men that's
actually traumatizing and end up
trusting them again
i mean i wouldn't lie it's it's a heart
you know it's very hard to
associate even like intimacy something
positive thing
every time when you had it was all
painful and not something good like when
i
remember when i was being raped i left
my body
and believing that's not me like i would
keep denier about it that's how insane i
was about it and
but the thing is like the perspective
again like my father was man
seriously he was the most loving man
i've ever had and i think
being rational and logical is what's
missing people just keep
so emotional and they don't think
rationally like they cannot be like over
three billion something men cannot be
all rapists right
so it is when we try to talk about
things in the emotional way how you
feel there's never way to solve that
because how you feel really
doesn't matter with how things actually
work
so i would like rather how rather it's
thinking about how
those rapists make me fear i think like
oh let's
think about this like you know maybe the
guys that i made in china
since i was 13 though all the ones who
was involved in gang and human
trafficking
that's why they were guys bad not
because men are bad
and but in the beginning entire two
years every man i saw were rapists and
it's hard to believe that men are good
but once you get out of the situation
thankfully you can see that like not the
man is bad yeah
like that guns are not bad like the
people who use it to kill others is bad
it's not like the
gun itself is a problem so
just people like just really stop like
think talking about their feelings and
thinking about actual real logic and
common sense
yeah all right well they're we seem to
be missing some of that at the moment
that's a lot of it actually a lot of it
yeah yeah
okay well that was a lot to take in
um where can where can people find you
online
i have been trying i mean i mean
i keep censored by like youtube but i'm
still trying to have my channel there
and i really try to talk about what is
happening to nursing people
the the news that cnn bbc new york times
doesn't cover
north korea is always portrayed in the
light of you know
nuclear weapons and crazy dictators
haircuts that's all they cover
they don't talk about actually what
nurse people are going through
and the immediately humanized north
koreans so much
that like actually in the beginning
whenever i talk to i met south koreans
and i tell them like i'm from north
korea they were like
oh my god you look like me they didn't
even think the north koreans would like
them
and just so it was so hard to humanize
north korean people again and
that's what i'm trying to do i on my
youtube channel i tried to like
show the average people and
why these people's rights matters like
if there's some polar bear matters
if some cats and puppies matters like
another human being shouldn't matter too
there's so many people like fighting for
a lot of things you know it's not like
i'm asking them to drop everything you
do and i'm fighting for human rights but
not enough people fighting for another
human being
that is very disheartening to see like
tons of people passionate about you know
reservations where yeah like animals
like if
if we ever did that with that education
to save another human
nobody have to be living under
oppression
but somehow humanity is so weird thing
like that's why i keep thinking about
what does it mean to be a human
like and like really that's why i keep
like reading about this of what does it
mean
to be a human and i don't know
completely the answer but it's like
we should like look into what's wrong
with us like we care about so much about
other things and not about another human
being
yeah well it's a lot it's a much more
difficult
problem to solve than you know i mean
not eating meat is pretty like that it's
not much of an effort
really it's like not good for people but
it's not much of an effort but actually
trying to help another person that takes
a lot of effort
and people don't know how i mean with
this north korean
situation i mean i don't even think
governments know how
um especially if you're talking about
like the power china has i mean
that's like i wouldn't know how to even
start to tackle that
your idea do you have ideas there yeah i
think it's definitely
actually not that hard it's not a
hopeless situation right
because the u.s is still the number one
power in the world
we have a lot of power over china if
they really started negotiating these
things like tell
china right on the face you cannot
sponsor this holocaust for north korean
people
it's not i'm saying it's a hollow
because the united nations
they did a massive uh conduct of
research on this issue around 2014
and then their conclusion what they came
up with is like the only resemblance we
can find
what is happening to nordstrom people is
a holocaust that's their words using the
word holocaust
and the u.n is the most conservative
organization they are going to call that
right
and then why are you not stopping it's
happening again
why are we denying it again it's like
history is repeating
stuff like people in their gas chambers
oh that's not happening
and now it happened and it's happening
in north korea we say oh that cannot be
true
how is that possible and this is like
what
just so frustrates me like it's humanity
what it is like why are we
repeating the same mistake over and over
again with even communism too like every
country tried every time it failed and
trump keep trying it again and again
again faded again
and this is like driving me nuts like we
have done this
why are we going this path again and i
think that what governments can do is
like if the people
like you and me everyone in this country
we are still living under democracy
if we wrote a letter to senators and
like congress people
and saying i want you to stop these
human rights crimes
that are happening to the people i want
you to stop like as people like
passing so many laws to stop everything
happening right
and this can be so easily done once we
demand from
our politicians because they're gonna
get to whatever that
get them votes and this has to be our
priority that
they act for human rights they should
defend human rights
but the people don't demand that they
demand a lot of other things
like creating safe spaces for people
like that's what they're demanding like
creating bathrooms for different people
i mean that's great
they are sure fight for it but like why
are we not there people
fighting as passionate about fighting
for bathroom right
it's just that's the thing it's a very
good question
so easy to make a change it's so easy to
fight for another human
easier than fighting for like so many
things they are fighting right now
so you know if people go like i have
nothing to order against blm it's okay
you fight for
racism that's great and why then like
are you not fighting for other slavery
it's happening right now like that like
people
if the people care i think there's
always a
way to fight for it but the thing is
people just don't care
i think that's what's the problem nice
my hope would be the reason people don't
care is because they're not educated
so i guess the step would be awareness
create enough awareness and then that'll
get people motivated i mean
anyone who would read your book would be
motivated and i like i said i haven't
finished it i'm part way through and
it's completely heartbreaking
so you raise awareness that way so
spread your story get other people to
talk about their stories
then get people to care and then get
them to rally the government
and yes work your way up from the bottom
exactly wow that should be the goal we
should
keep talking about what is chinese peace
doing to
their people even in muslims i don't
know what happened to all these people
who talks about like muslim like is a
great religion we cannot challenge them
and suddenly millions of in the
concentration camp
and like nobody's talking about it when
americans
like politicians talk about something
bad or maybe
debating of idea of muslim or religion
what it does to people but now
in their millions concentrating him by
chinese regime
and like what happened to those any of
those critics i just don't get it like a
water hypocrite this is
like you know that's very strange that's
very strange because there is a lot of
talk about
you know islamophobia and don't be don't
be against muslim people but then
when there's something actually
happening yeah everyone's quiet about it
yeah millions actually in the
concentration camp in china by not being
sterilized
being tortured to be raped being killed
organ harvesting they take the organs
out of these people
in china like this this is happening
right now
and just like it was kept silent
i think it's so awful and
people have it so good here
[Music]
generally speaking that you listen to it
and you go
nah okay i don't want that to be real
like that is way too bad like
it's difficult to even believe that
humans can be that terrible to each
other
and you learn about what happened uh you
know in world war ii and the holocaust
um but it's hard but then people say oh
well those were nazis and they were the
bad guys and they're not
you know they're not around anymore it
wouldn't like i wouldn't have done that
type of thing uh instead of recognizing
that
many people can be evil and that it's
still like this kind of evil still
widespread so
it is hard for people i think to rap i
mean it's hard for me to wrap my head
around it
yeah i mean the thing is that the
resemblance i see right now is that like
when the nazis took juice in the
beginning right they didn't even stand
up for them
because i mean a lot of them didn't
that's why he went that far
and like right now there are people
being cancered losing their jobs
and for saying things that is not
politically correct
and we think oh it's never gonna affect
me so i'm gonna keep silent and pretend
that i'm
like one of these correct group
it's gonna harm us all eventually no one
is like winning this game
other than the the final result of the
final that
huge government you're gonna get we are
like in this thing and
no one is gonna win and that's the thing
like in north korea nobody is a human
except kim jong-un nobody has the right
to be a human
and just and people are saying oh how in
america all this like democratic
socialism they are fighting who is never
the same thing with the
north korean things like or no it's like
in america already like we
have to put on this mask and we get
fined and in south korea if you don't
you can't even go to prison for it right
now
wow okay well i think that's a good
place to end it
uh thank you very much i learned an
incredible amount and
um i would recommend whoever's listening
to
check out the book thank you and it is
available
on what should people what should people
type in where should they go
it's like amazon everywhere it is um
yeah
if you want to get a glimpse of what
actual hardship is like and
cry a bunch and learn something i would
uh highly recommend it so thank you
thank you very much for coming on oh
thank you so much for everything you do
and giving me this platform to have a
voice
it means a lot
you